[Música]
una poderosa tormenta invernal azota
buena parte del territorio de Estados
Unidos el fenómeno climático ha
provocado Que las temperaturas
desciendan hasta 50 grados bajo cero dos
mil vuelos han sido cancelados y más de
100 millones de personas han sido
afectadas
y después de una demanda por parte del
Gobierno Federal por invadir terrenos
federales y dañar el medio ambiente las
autoridades del estado de Arizona en
Estados Unidos se vieron obligadas a
eliminar el muro de contenedores
instalado en la ya militarizada y
concurrida frontera con México
la asamblea nacional de Venezuela
elegida en 2015 votó para eliminar la
figura del gobierno interino que es
liderado por Juan guaidó bajo el
argumento de ser una estrategia política
fallida guaidó afirmó que esta medida
beneficiará al gobierno de Nicolás
maduro
Bienvenidos a este informativo de France
24 en el que hacemos énfasis en los
temas de nuestro continente América
vamos a comenzar en Estados Unidos que
vivirá tal vez su Navidad más fría desde
1980 así lo indicó el servicio
meteorológico al anunciar que la mayoría
de los estados se verán afectados por
una tormenta invernal que ya está
provocando un descenso considerable en
las temperaturas en algunos puntos del
país han llegado a registrarse hasta 50
grados bajo cero previo a la temporada
navideña cerca de 2000 vuelos ya han
sido cancelados el reporte es de Andrés
triviño
Estados Unidos vivirá una vida más fría
en cuatro décadas casi todos los estados
del país sienten los estragos de la gran
tormenta invernal Elliot la cual deja
más de 90 millones de personas en alerta
máxima principalmente en el medio oeste
y la región de los grandes lagos por lo
que las autoridades han estado a sus
ciudadanos a tomarse en serio la
tormenta
no es un día de nieve normal como cuando
eran niños en serio y mi equipo está
listo para ayudar a las comunidades a
sobrellevar esta tormenta
se espera que Durante los próximos días
Elliot se convierta en una bomba
ciclónica con ráfagas de viento tan
fuertes que pueden alcanzar el
equivalente a un huracán categoría 3
provocando hasta 30 cm de nieve y
temperaturas entre los 10 y los 20
grados bajo cero este jueves Más de
2.200 vuelos fueron cancelados y se
espera que la situación empeore tanto en
las vías como en los aeropuertos siendo
una de las festividades en las que los
estadounidenses más se movilizan debido
a que tenemos que movernos más despacio
tenemos que establecer programar o
reducir nuestro horario
ha sido un poco loco llegué temprano
para asegurarme de tomar mi vuelo y a la
puerta de embarque cuando me enteré que
Fue cancelado las aerolíneas
estadounidenses anunciaron que trabajan
para que Los viajeros puedan reunirse en
Navidad y eliminarán las tarifas de
cambio a Los afectados por la tormenta
y entre tanto las autoridades del estado
de Arizona también en Estados Unidos
acordaron eliminar el gigantesco muro de
contenedores que está instalado en la
frontera con México expertos han
señalado que pone en peligro a numerosas
especies locales que están amenazadas
Valentina Torres Sánchez tiene los
detalles
son más de 900 los contenedores que
fueron ubicados en el bosque nacional
Coronado en la frontera sur del estado
de Arizona y ahora tendrán que ser
removidos el gobernador republicano
tras la demanda Federal presentada a
principios de diciembre el muro fue
diseñado para disuadir el paso de
migrantes irregulares calificado de
siniestro por el gobernador pero la
demanda indica que los contenedores
fueron ubicados de forma ilegal en
terrenos federales y ponen en peligro la
vida Silvestre
es el lugar de una increíble diversidad
de vida Silvestre una de las áreas de
conservación más importantes de todo
Estados Unidos
es una parte de la frontera muy difícil
de cruzar para los migrantes y hasta
donde sabemos no hay mucha actividad
migratoria
el plazo para remover los contenedores
se cumple el próximo cuatro de enero dos
días después de que la demócrata Katy
hobbes asuma como gobernadora
la situación se presenta justamente
cuando crece el temor por la llegada de
miles de migrantes a ciudades del Norte
de México mientras esperan que expire el
llamado título 42 que permitía la
expulsión Express por motivos sanitarios
la nueva oleada ha hecho que las
autoridades de México y Estados Unidos
aumenten la presencia militar pero los
migrantes no están dispuestos a
retirarse estamos en Navidad muchos
están compartiendo con su familia uno se
tuvo que venir fuera de su familia
y sus hijos pasando necesidad Pues hay
un 24 de diciembre que tú no sabes dónde
van a dormir en principio quedaba
derogada el 21 de diciembre pero la
Corte Suprema lo aplazó hasta el día 27
la normativa ha permitido expulsar a más
de un millón de migrantes y su
eliminación significa una luz de
esperanza en su búsqueda por una nueva
vida
nos vamos ahora hasta Venezuela allí los
ex diputados de la asamblea nacional
elegida en el 2015 votaron a favor de
eliminar la figura del gobierno interino
que lidera el opositor Juan guaidó en
una primera sesión los exdiputados
votaron 72 votos a favor de la
eliminación y 23 en contra lo que deja
entonces en la cuerda floja la
permanencia de Juan guaidó como rostro
de la oposición política contra el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro un segundo
debate tendrá lugar el 29 de diciembre y
será en esa fecha cuando el legislativo
venezolano tome una decisión definitiva
Cuáles herramientas tenemos hoy para
enfrentar a esta dictadura la unidad la
primera reforzado hoy con la plataforma
unitaria y la convocatoria primaria
también el acuerdo de gobernabilidad
parlamental que debe respetar este
parlamento nacional para conservar el
poder legítimo que de nuevo y como le
decía Hace unos días se lo digo a
Venezuela se instala el 5 de enero las
pretensiones también de la dictadura de
querer acabar con el parlamento electo
en 2015 y entre tanto en Chile el
presidente Gabriel borich anunció que su
país abrirá una embajada en Palestina
decisión que no ha escapado de la
controversia en ese país chile al igual
que otros países alrededor del mundo
tiene una representación ante la
autoridad Palestina Pero esta decisión
convierte al país suramericano en el
primer estado del mundo en contar con
una representación diplomática oficial
en territorio palestino Esto no es una
coincidencia dado que chile alberga la
mayor comunidad Palestina fuera de medio
oriente también reconoció a este
territorio como un estado y también
respaldó su ingreso en la UNESCO
vamos a Elevar el carácter de nuestra
representación oficial en Palestina de
encargado de negocios que hoy día vamos
a abrir una embajada durante nuestro
gobierno para darle
la representación que corresponde y
exigir exigir en todos los espacios algo
tan básico algo tan básico tan simple
pero que hoy día nos está haciendo que
es que se respete el derecho
internacional ni nada más ni nada menos
ya poco menos de 10 días de asumir el
cargo el presidente electo de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva dio a conocer
parte de lo que será su gabinete de
ministros entre los nombramientos se
destacan algunas figuras de la escena
política brasileña también hay
representantes de los pueblos
afrodescendientes e indígenas hasta el
momento seis mujeres han sido escogidas
para llevar alguna de estas carteras
son los primeros nombres del gabinete de
Lula el presidente electo de Brasil
anunció a 16 de sus nuevos ministros que
asumirán junto a él el primero de enero
los ministerios asignados fueron entre
otros Salud Educación ciencia y
tecnología relaciones exteriores defensa
cultura igualdad racial y Derechos
Humanos destacan entre los designados la
asignación del vicepresidente electo
Gerardo alquim en el Ministerio de
industrias y comercio exterior Daniel
Franco hermana de la asesinada activista
Mariel y Franco y Silvio Almeida un
activista contra el racismo estarán al
frente de los departamentos de igualdad
racial y Derechos Humanos
respectivamente dos de sus hombres de
confianza figuran en la lista rui Costa
estará al frente del Ministerio de la
presidencia mientras que Fernando jadad
ex alcalde de Sao Paulo estará a cargo
de Hacienda El canciller será Mauro
vieira quien ya realizó estas funciones
bajo las órdenes de Dilma Rousseff Lula
anunció que aumentará 37 los ministerios
el actual gobierno cuenta con 23 no soy
yo quien necesita a los ministros que
anunciamos es el pueblo brasileño quien
los necesita los pobres las mujeres la
población negra nuestro compromiso es
con el pueblo y estoy seguro de que
sabremos cumplirlo aún no se conoce
quién dirigirá el Ministerio de medio
ambiente uno de los nombramientos más
esperados incluso a nivel internacional
y de acuerdo con los últimos reportes
médicos la salud de Edson arantes en tu
nacimiento mejor conocido como Pelé
empeoró y sus familiares y amigos más
cercanos han comenzado a despedirse del
Astro del fútbol brasileño Pelé de 82
años lleva ya tres semanas internado en
un hospital de la ciudad de Sao Paulo en
donde su estado ha desmejorado con el
paso de los días a causa de un cáncer de
coloque de colon que enfrenta el
deportista Está también recibiendo
cuidados para sobrellevar la disfunción
renal y cardíaca que está presentando
y vamos a terminar en Quito en la
capital ecuatoriana donde se encuentra
el pesebre bíblico más grande de América
Latina habitualmente este pesebre es
exhibido en la Ciudad de Loja pero este
año fue trasladado a la catedral de
Quito y a cautivado a los cientos de
visitantes que recorren el centro
histórico de la ciudad cerca de 1600
figuras hacen parte de esta recreación
ampliamente extendida en América Latina
en donde recibe diferentes nombres como
ya les dijimos pesebre o portales
nacimientos o simplemente Belén
con estas imágenes despedimos esta
informativo siga con France 24
[Música]